like gustavo mention i mean film work i
mean i do several things i play in a
group called by a phone though i produce
a terrorist i do music for films but
today talking about films films it is a
collaborative effort so it is really a
team work and i think what well i would
expect that this relates to the other
activities too i expect people to live
to affect people in a positive way with
my work I like people when they leave a
concern when they leave a movie that I
was part of to somehow when L live with
with new ways of looking at reality you
know I think art that's what it is art
is a way of reorganizing reality in a
peculiar way they're always the same
note it's just a different way we put
them together that makes the composition
one compositions or another compositions
so I I hope that that my work affects
people in a positive way that leaves
them thinking wondering more about life
and about the mysteries of life and how
can we connect and understand better
each other and we do that through the
movies a lot because just by seeing
other people's stories we see things
that reflect who we are sometimes or
people that we know and we can learn and
and change and transform ourselves so
basically I would say that that would be
the main thing affect people in a
positive way and in relationship of what
is that drive me I have to to go back to
when I was a kid I have a very clear
realization that when when I sort of
connect with with music and I was I was
raised Catholic as I was we're going to
be a priest I'm not a Catholic anymore
i'ma agnostic now but but I had a better
herrick always a big connection between
the music and in the spirit I think I
mean there
solutely collected and so that's the
place that I always like to go back to I
like to go back to that kid I like to go
back to that space that is inside of me
and that I tried to protect how I can
and that connects me with a sense of
innocence of danger and enough and
educated knowledge so that's that's
that's when I connect with that I know I
mean in good territory to to do a piece
of music